if you're hoping to survive tonight's
debate here are two Pro tips one is the
Donald Trump complete sentence drinking
game every time he completes a sentence
you take a drink at the end of the night
you will be completely sober and you
will see exactly how much of a
mountebank this man is the second is the
Donald Trump translation device provided
by the man who was his ghostwriter on
his book the art of the deal which they
may yet reissue under the title my
struggle Tony Schwartz tweeted this on
July 27th and it is is invaluable as the
rosetta stone
something I saw early on with Trump he
wrote most negative things he says about
others are actually describing him read
his tweets with that in mind projection
psychologists and psychiatrists call it
you say it about somebody else you're
actually confessing to it the more angry
or accusatory you are the more guilty
you are of it you don't believe this
March 26 the media is so after me on
women wow this is a tough business
nobody has more respect for women than
Donald Trump Washington Post October 7th
quote I moved on her actually you know
she was down on Palm Beach I moved on
her and I failed I'll admit it quote I
did try and [ __ ] her she was married
quote and I moved on a very heavily in
fact I took her out furniture shopping
she wanted to get some furniture
I said I'll show you where they have
some nice furniture quotes I moved on
her like a [ __ ] but I couldn't get
there and she was married quote then all
of a sudden I see her she's now got the
big phony tits and everything she's
totally changed her look quotes I better
use some tic-tacs just in case I start
kissing her you know I'm automatically
attracted to beautiful I just start
kissing them it's like a magnet just
kiss I don't even wait when you're a
star they let you do it you can do
anything
quote grab them by the [ __ ] you can do
anything yes respect for women it came
shining through on the Billy Bush tape
grab those women buy the respect even
last Saturday nothing ever happened with
any of these women totally made-up
nonsense to steal the election nobody
has more respect for women than me right
like Nancy O'Dell
you did say you tried to respect her
Trump respected on her like a [ __ ]
but tipping your hand like this this is
nothing new right last December 28th if
Hillary thinks you can unleash your
husband with this terrible record of
women abuse while playing the woman's
card on me she's wrong oh we have you
now Trump as we watch you in the debate
tonight with whatever atrocity you have
planned to pin on Secretary Clinton we
have your proverbial tell I mean you're
not only give away what's going on in
your sick mind now you also give away
what's gone on in the past and you're
close to being psychic about your own
future September 30th did crooked
Hillary help disgusting
check out sex tape and past Alicia am
become a US citizen
so she could use her in the debate sex
tape you say Trump that tweet was seven
days before your sex tape came out the
one with Billy Bush the one in which you
told him that you better use some
tic-tacs just in case you started
respecting Arianne sucker you know
because you just start respecting them
it's like a magnet just respect you
don't even wait so does the projection
method explain other topics of yours
Trump August 23rd it is being reported
by virtually everyone and is a fact that
the media pile-on against me is the
worst in American political history wait
so the media is reporting that the media
is piling on you so that's about your
efforts to bully the media it must be
very difficult even for you to try and
figure yourself out August 12 I love
watching these poor pathetic people
pundits on television working so hard
and so seriously to try and figure me
out they can't so that means you work so
hard and seriously to try to figure you
out
and you can't I'm actually going to
agree with you on that one Don d this is
from last weekend tweet number eleventy
billion on this topic
Hillary Clinton should have been
prosecuted and should be in jail instead
she is running for president what looks
like a rigged election so you should
have been prosecuted and you should be
in jail and you were trying to rig the
election got it
if only we could find out how you're
trying to rig the election the election
is absolutely being rigged by the
dishonest and distorted media pushing
crooked Hillary but also at many polling
places said but Trump since nearly all
the polling places are not even set up
yet it's three weeks before the election
how could you know that the way to rig
the election was by intimidation or
hacking at the polling places unless oh
but you couldn't be doing all that by
yourself could you
October 4th Clinton's close ties to
Putin deserves scrutiny so all the Putin
stories about you were true Trump too
bad we couldn't gain insight into what
you think should be done about all that
if I win I'm going to instruct my
Attorney General to get a special
prosecutor to look into your situation
because there's never been anything like
your lies you're not making this one
very difficult dandelion that tweet
didn't even have anybody else's name
attached to it it reads like a guy
talking to himself in a mirror well we
got the idea Trump so thank you for
picking out of all people in the world
Tony Schwartz to write your book for you
and then years later provide us the
donald da vinci code but how do those
wise words about projection most
negative things he says about others are
actually describing him read his tweets
with that in mind how do they apply to
tonight's debate Hillary Clinton is
taking the day off again
she needs the rest sleep well Hillary
see you at the debate so you're a little
tired Trump doing anything for it a nice
cappuccino little red bowl once again
the answer is in your words though I am
cheating a little here this is from a
speech not a tweet October 15th I think
we should take a drug test prior to the
debate because I don't know what's going
on with her but at the beginning of her
last debate she was all pumped up at the
beginning and at the end it was like
huff take me down she could barely reach
her car drugs huh okay ante up big fella
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space